uh that i've got i've got like the next
one it's called the smooth paper
i've been handed uh pieces of paper
before juiced at conventions you know
i'll do i'll just like sign something or
i'll take a picture and i'll change me a
piece of paper
right i'll be like hey here's my number
come text me i think that's kind of
smooth
that's very old stuff i don't know why
that's smooth i never replied to any of
them because i'm like bro
my phone doesn't work in the u.s sorry
rip i just have internet but
it's very smooth i like it i actually
like that one i think it's classy now
you're going to now you're going to get
this
every conversation because it's like
it's like with this one it's like it's
not intense it's like
i i if i want to call you i'll call you
i'm not gonna call you just letting you
know
because i'm too [ __ ] just the casual
right that's that's how i imagine people
yeah there's something simple about it
that's so inoffensive
but maybe it's because i'm a guy i feel
like if i was a girl and guys kept doing
it to me i'd be like annoyed
yeah that would be very creepy yeah yeah
i kind of like it it's very flattering
when someone is
attractive and they send you you know
they they hit on you it's like oh wow
this league really oh no get out of here
i thought
we weren't even playing the same sport
dude i thought i was playing checkers
you're playing 4d
chess this don't match but yeah i mean
you know i mean it's a nice ego boost
for like 20 minutes until you realize
that
he realizes a bit weird yeah he realized
that's a bit strange golden rule don't
[ __ ] your fans right
yeah exactly especially in this climate
i i just think that's like
oh yeah honestly yeah dude whenever i
used to
because for the first like two three
months in japan i was using i
i had like tinder because i thought no
one's gonna recognize me on tinder
fantastic
yeah but yeah those people who recognize
me on tinder here who could speak
english obviously and then obviously a
white guy would stand out right
yeah and they were like oh i watch your
videos i'm like immediately unmatched
yeah yeah
honestly like see you did you played it
smart
why would i wanna i don't want to date
someone who turns up and they're like
yo i love that video whoa whoa whoa whoa
well because i thought
unfortunately there's a lot of youtubers
who probably use that as an ego booster
right
i mean okay getting in the whole topic
of [ __ ] your fans or dating your fans
there is a way to go about it there is a
right way
and there is definitely a wrong way like
yeah they they met through being fans
yeah and there was a that no one ever
would question the the
what's the word legitimacy the
legitimacy or
the efficacy of that right that's a
legitimate relationship
but there are ways doing it that that
like taking advantage of your power and
i think that's where people have the
problem yeah yeah and unfortunately
a lot of youtubers don't understand when
they are just kind of taking advantage
of their own power yeah in the situation
yeah i i feel i feel like like hooking
up like i say hooking up hooking up the
wrong words because if
hooking up with your fans implies that
yeah you you are just kind of just like
you're not doing anything you're just
kind of throwing throwing your fame out
there and everything like that yeah and
i feel like you have to be really
self-conscious about this and i'm glad
that
people are like looking more into this
and like i'm like
putting more attention getting smarter
about it yeah and fans are getting
smarter about this as well as they
really should be
um and it's the responsibility you hold
as a youtuber
and sometimes you just don't want to
worry about that you just want to meet
someone where you don't want to have to
worry about this power imbalance because
you you are you know we're all just
people as well we're all just people and
sometimes we just want to
switch off this part of our lives and
just be a normal [ __ ] person like
anyone else
um yeah i don't want someone who's
watches my videos and has an expectation
of me in general that i can from that
that is portrayed through right
right yeah it's funny because most of
the friends i've made
who started off as fans like as we
became friends
they just started watching less and less
my stuff and because that's because
that's that in a lot of the ways that
made me more comfortable or they we
stopped talking about it because
they were just mates and we would talk
like mates and talk about
whatever else apart from my job as i'm
sure
i kind of feel that works in the same
way with like friends between two
youtubers right
yeah i definitely like watch like less
of like my
youtuber friends videos after we just
kind of went
past that point just became friends no
you you keep up with it just just to see
what your mates are doing yeah yeah
but you're not like damn bro that last
video [ __ ] banger bro
like i would have done this differently
yeah like i like showing sports my mates
you know yeah
it's different from being like yo i'm a
huge fan of what you did
[ __ ] yes [ __ ] banger right there yeah
yeah it's
man life's hard if you're you should
if you want to just be safe don't [ __ ]
your face rule number one
working good for me yeah yeah oh my god
uh this is my stock image can you
explain why you chose this
okay so there is a labrador with a gun
holding her
i just thought it was fun you know okay
sure i don't know it's just kind of fun
this is what happens when you reach like
the end of your project and you're just
like i'll just throw whatever [ __ ] i put
oh we're about halfway we're about
halfway okay okay the next one start
getting a bit more
okay uh you've been hit on the youtube
comment section of course yeah of course
yeah of course
yeah take me on a date next time i visit
japan that happens
yeah that happens a few of those
comments it's like uh no how about how
about you pay for my date
yeah i wonder if anyone is ever in the
history of youtube probably has
would have taken a comment like that
seriously and i mean that tried to
pursue it
i mean i mean maybe if you like a
smaller youtuber maybe yeah i mean i did
something similar along with like email
someone emailed me asking me to go on a
date
but there's a difference
um anyone can write a youtube call the
live and then obviously you know people
ask you on dates on live streams all the
time
you're just you're streaming yeah i get
comments sometimes being like oh we're
on a day and we're in japan all
people people subtly ask questions that
are like
i think that they think they're being
subtle right but it's very obvious what
they're asking
like for example one very big giveaway
as to what some people are asking um are
like hey
uh would you do like long distance
relationships just uh
and like some people might genuinely be
curious right but there's like a way
that certain people ask it that is like
uh no no you know that kind of gives you
that vibe of like
you're asking this for a purpose yeah
and also
i get donations sometimes which i think
that's another one actually
but um where people will be like oh um
just like wondering like what kind of
age age group do you go for
uh if it isn't obvious by now uh milfs
all the milfs rise up so you know you
know if you're if you're
around my age lonely housewives just
kidding
they're preparing the walls for the next
stream is your husband just not cutting
it
i don't want to know who he is but i'm
kidding
yeah i mean yeah stuff like that what
else do i get there's ones as well you
know what i get asked a fair amount
which
is like the least subtle which is like
would you ever date someone who like
doesn't do youtube and i'm like well do
you think i exclusively date psychopaths
like whatever you think no i only
exclusively date youtubers that's weird
i don't have at least ten thousands well
you guys date youtubers but i couldn't
imagine dating a youtuber
i mean i started dating her when she had
like less than a thousand subs so it's a
little bit different i mean i convinced
my girl to become a youtuber yeah
so you brought them into the play yeah
we brought them in i wouldn't want my
sniffing other to be a youtuber why
i don't know i don't want to [ __ ]
deal with another me that's [ __ ]
awful
and like my schedule's such a mess
already i wouldn't like a relationship
to me like that would be such a [ __ ]
mess if both of us had similar schedules
like that i mean i don't blame you
there's lots of people who are lazy i
mean that's just
me i mean that's just what i want yeah i
feel that's just how our relationships
ended up
yeah true it's just a standard work
schedule